hello and welcome to event driven
microservices with cloudrun
my name is prashant gulati so how do you
know if you're in the right session
today
you're in the right session today if
you're looking to learn more about
working with events
for use cases in video analysis
file conversion new user signup
application monitoring or hundreds of
others
if you're looking to learn about how to
act on events originating from
cloud storage bigquery
or dozens of other google cloud sources
and if you're looking to modernize to
event-driven architectures
and improve both developer productivity
and your bottom line
let's get started i'm going to be
covering four topics today
we'll start by describing the rise of
microservices and some of the problems
inherent in them
we'll then move on to describe
event-driven architectures and how they
solve some of those problems
we'll introduce you to google cloud's
new offerings in this space
events for cloud run and events for
cloudron for anthos
and we'll conclude by showing you a
sentiment analysis demo which takes in a
complex image and performs sentiment
analysis on it
let's start by describing the rise of
microservices
there are several architectural styles
in software
monoliths for instance perhaps your
organization has monoliths
we're going to take you on a journey
today from monoliths
to microservices to event-driven
microservices
let's start with monoliths they're
fairly easy to understand
as you can see on the screen here here's
an e-commerce store with six
component services
there's a few problems that are inherent
in any monolith
scalability component services
scale as a group and not individually
extensibility it's hard to add or update
services and lastly coupling
there are often couple dependencies
between services that you have to deal
with
in a monolith
so to address some of these problems you
might want to chart
a migration to microservices
by pulling out component services into
separate services
let's take a look at the example over
here we've pulled out a couple of
component services the newsletter and
the shop
as we continue this migration and pull
out a third service you start to see the
connections between the services develop
as we pull out a fourth service the
connections between them
deepen further
we've now completed the migration to
microservices
while we've started to address some of
the issues with scalability
extensibility and coupling we haven't
done so completely
we've improved on scalability but
there's still a question of whether the
communication between services is
synchronous
or asynchronous that makes a difference
we've improved on extensibility
however the new services that we add
may still require that we make updates
to
existing services that are going to
communicate with that new service
and lastly while we've made coupling
looser
it's possible that different services
may still have couple dependencies
on a message queue for instance which
you may want to take a dependency on
if you're looking to protect against
intermittent failure
of services
in addition to the three problems that
we've only solved partially
microservices also introduce three new
problems
for one there's a spiderweb of
point-to-point integrations like you saw
in the previous slide
there's the potential for expensive
inter-service communication
especially if the communication between
services is full style say via polling
there's also the potential for
non-uniform communication format
between services
we continue our evolution onto event
driven architectures
but first let's start by describing what
is an event
there's three concepts to think about
here occurrences
events and actions in the operation of a
software system
an occurrence is when something happens
a statement of fact about something
happening
an event is a record expressing that
occurrence and its context
and an action will take place based on
an occurrence
which is communicated to a service
through an event
now events originate asynchronously and
with events a producer has no
expectation
of how the event might be handled by a
consumer
let's take a look at a typical
event-driven architecture or an eda
multiple event producers go ahead and
produce
events and send them on to event
intermediaries
at the other end event consumers
subscribe to the events
in particular that they're interested in
from specific producers
now eda's solved several of the problems
that we identified earlier
[Music]
let's start by looking at scalability
take a look at these two systems that
you see in front of you
one can handle 200 transactions a second
and the second can handle
100 transactions a second now with just
a micro services architecture
where the communication between them is
synchronous
a request response style the weakest
link dictates the peak
throughput of the system
but if you then graduate onto event
driven microservices
the weakest link now dictates the
sustained throughput of the system
let's take a look at extensibility and
how it's easier to add services with
event driven architectures
we have a couple of event producers and
a couple of event consumers
we're going to go ahead and add another
event consumer
when we add an event consumer no changes
need to be made
to any producer thus making
extensibility a lot easier
let me highlight some of the other
benefits of event driven architectures
we can now decouple from dependencies
completely the event intermediary can
handle intermittent unavailability of
services
there's no more spider web no more
point-to-point integrations
event producers can just fire events and
forget about them
events are pushed and this replaces
pull-based
polling and lastly there's an
opportunity to introduce a standardized
format
a uniform communication format between
services
for instance cloud events format with an
ideal event-driven architecture system
users no longer have to be experts in
distributed computing
they can take event ingestion delivery
security
authorization observability and error
handling for granted
and just focus on their application code
for their use case
this brings us to google cloud's new
offerings in this space
you're already familiar with some of
google cloud's offerings to help you
with microservices
cloudrun cloudrun helps you run any
stateless container on google's fully
managed infrastructure
and there's cloudrun for anthos which
helps you run any stateless container on
google kubernetes engine
is k native conformant and helps you
achieve portability
to other clouds or on-prem today we
introduce to you
two new capabilities to help you with
event driven micro services
events for cloud run and events for
cloud cloudra inferentials
both these capabilities help you easily
build event driven architectures
let's take a look at both of these
capabilities one after the other
with events for cloud run you can set up
triggers
to act on events sourced from all google
cloud sources
via cloud audit logs for instance
cloud storage a popular google cloud
source via cloud audit logs
you can also act on events from custom
applications
that publish events to cloud pops up
events for cloud run delivers these
events to cloud run targets
let's now talk about events for cloudron
for anthos
events for quadrant for anthos is
k-native-based and incorporates the
concepts of k-native brokers
and triggers with events for quadrant
for anthos
you can act on events sourced from
all google cloud sources via cloud art
logs
cloud storage and cloud scheduler in
particular which are native integrations
custom applications that are publishing
events to cloud pub sub
and also custom events you can target
cloudrun for anthos targets kubernetes
services
and also any url with both events for
cloud run and events for cloud run for
enthos
they both handle event ingestion
delivery
security authorization observability and
error handling for you
they both have the same delivery
guarantees as cloud pub sub
at least once delivery for example
they both provide on-demand scalability
and cost
and you can operate both of them through
a ui cli
or api interface
both events for cloud run and events for
cloud9 for anthos deliver events in
cloud events format
this also allows you the user to use
cloud events available sdks in multiple
languages
to be able to work with your cloudants
we also provide libraries to help you
unmarshal the event data
within climates i'd now like to take you
through a sentiment analysis demo
showing you
the use of events for cloud run and
events for cloud9 for enthus
we're going to take a complex image and
process it
with an event driven architecture system
that we're going to build
for example take a look at this image
here of a family
now the holidays bring out all kinds of
different emotions in different members
of the family
what we're going to try to do here is
from an input image
draw out each family member
and determine what their sentiments are
what their sentiment score is
all using event driven architectures now
to accomplish such an event-driven
architecture
there's a few micro services that we're
going to need
a cloud storage bucket
a firestore database
and a few different compute services
these can be cloud run services or cloud
run for antho services
to start we need one service which can
help us extract the bounding boxes
of faces from the original image
we need another that can extract face
images
from those bounding boxes
a third that can run those faces through
an open
neural network exchange model and then
generate an emotion score from them
a fourth that can write those scores to
a firestore database
and a fifth to render a user interface
now let's take a look at how we can
stitch these services together in an
event-driven architecture
let's go back to this diagram which
you're familiar with from earlier in the
presentation
we have event producers and event
consumers with an event intermediary in
the middle
let's now bring in some of the
microservices we need for our specific
demo
here you see the cloud storage bucket
the firestore database
and the five compute services that we
identified
as a reminder these can be cloud run
cloud run for anthos
or a combination of the two
as we start to put this service together
let's walk through the flow
and start the stitching together
a user uploads an image to a cloud
storage bucket
this should then fire an event to an
event intermediary
that event is then sent to the first
compute service
the first compute service then sends a
custom
event published to pub sub back to the
event intermediary
this then reaches the second service the
second service extracts face images
and places them in a cloud storage
bucket
which then fires another event back to
the event intermediary
this then moves on to the third service
which runs those faces
through the open neural network exchange
model and generates the emotion scores
an event is then sent to the event
intermediary once again
which then reaches the fourth compute
service
the fourth compute service writes a
score to the firestore database
which then fires another event at the
event intermediary
and updates the user interface i'm now
going to show you a demo
in which we've already put together
several of the components of
the architecture i described but it's
missing one trigger so we're going to
wire up that trigger
and then we're going to also show you
the entire system
in operation
we're now going to head to the user
interface of one of our cloud run
services
this is the second cloud run service and
we need to add a trigger to it to allow
it to receive events from the first
cloud run service
to do this we're going to head to the
triggers tab
we're going to start by clicking on add
trigger
we're asked to specify a trigger name
we're going to leave the default
suggested value as is
we'll head to event type where we're
going to pick cloud pops up
this allows us to receive events
published to specific cloud pub sub
topics
we're asked to select a cloud pub sub
topic and i'm going to select one that
i'd already created earlier
as i click on save this will complete
trigger creation
and complete the setup of our event
driven architecture
i am now ready to head over to our cloud
storage bucket
to which i'm going to add the original
image of the family that we showed you
earlier
once again here's the image of the
family
i'm going to take this and drag this
into the cloud storage bucket
now that we've added this image to the
cloud storage bucket it's going to kick
off a series of events
as we described in the setup earlier
if all is well and working well when i
move over to the next tab which
represents the fifth cloud run service
for the user interface
we should see images for each of the
family members along with their
sentiment scores
so let's go take a look
here we are you see images of each of
the family members
the two parents on the right and the two
and the two children on the left
the parents have higher happiness scores
right after their happiness scores they
have neutrality scores
and the two children as you can see from
their facial expressions
have higher neutrality scores followed
by sadness scores
so what did we just see right now
we created an event driven rapid auto
scaling
scale to zero service
we created an event trigger and we
triggered cloud events to be sent
to cloud run services there's a few
key takeaways i'd like you to take away
from today's presentation
you as a user can transform your
company's i.t systems to enable
real-time business
so your customers and business users can
get what they want
when they want it and in doing so this
enables a layer of high value services
that really make a difference to the
bottom line of your business
i invite you to try both offerings we've
discussed today
events for cloud run is in private
preview and you can sign up by going to
bitly
event stash cr events for cloud9 for
anthos is also in private preview
and you can access it at bitly events cr
anthos both offerings are coming to
public preview by the end of september
of this year
and we invite you to join us when they
come to public preview
once again my name is prashant gulati my
email address
is my first name last name at google.com
i would love
to hear from you comments questions and
feedback
thank you very much i hope you enjoy the
rest of next